Cracker Barrel becomes latest company to
flee Portland amid Rising crime retail
theft
it is closing its final eateries in the
Portland metro area citing the impact of
kova 19 pandemic on its business the
closure are in Beaverton Tualatin and
bend our effective March 20th a
spokesperson for Cracker Barrel said the
pandemic had many had made it difficult
to staff and profitably run the stores
Walmart announced it was closing all of
its Portland stores in February citing
financial reasons the seal Walmart had
previously warned that stores would
close if retail crime didn't subside
crime and homelessness have been growing
issues in Portland over the past couple
of years
would over 2 600 downtown businesses
failing filling a change of address with
the U.S Postal Service a Nike store in
northeast Portland abruptly closed in
November 2022 it's a couple months ago
after string of brazen shoplifting
incidents a real estate developer and
lifelong Portland native Dustin Michael
Miller said the city was out of control
and unrecognizable Tom what do you have
to say about the story you wanted to
defend the police
you wanted to say that people are just
acting out because of Decades of
you know discrimination
you got it and this is the unintended
consequences and so why don't we just
substitute retail theft for excessive
gun control and that is exactly what is
happening in Oregon people are leaving
and now the law-abiding citizens and the
people that love Oregon like this guy
here says it's out of control and
unrecognizable unrecognizable means he
recognizes a time when it was different
when it was a time for his family and
what he was doing but this is not going
to stop defund the police this is the
polluted pond at the end so now what do
you do with the polluted Pond you go
Upstream you see what polluted it and
the Upstream problem was you allowed
what was the name of that little they
gave a name to the uh Rob the downtown
area they called it the something the
chat the chasing yeah where some people
took over the yeah downtown Portland
yeah they called it something which was
the it's an occupation of that yeah yeah
exactly this is our area no cops will be
allowed here and this is what's going on
here and occupy Portland yeah and and so
you got it you got what you asked for
you know and it's terrible and look
what's happened to the citizenry that
was not behind that you know 100 of the
people in Portland voters were not in
favor of defund the police they were not
in favor of you know oh just let the
looters go it's you know just sort of
economic redistribution really you
here's the outcome
everything's closing you you have an
uninhabitable City now what exactly and
the fact that they were blaming covert
it's like no just just be honest and say
listen we messed up we supported the
wrong policies but you know what I love
about this what here's what I love about
this you know
18 years ago I'm 25 years old we're
sitting in a room
with a bunch of other guys who are
around the same age and we start at the
same time with this insurance company
and everybody is bragging about the fact
that one thing's bigger than the other
they're hard of working they're better
leaders they're better Builders of
leaders all this other stuff right
you know how the meeting ended I said
we'll know in about 10 or 20 years oh
wow and and that's how this thing works
you realize one guy slowed down at a
certain number one guy the attention got
to his head one guy was all about the
girls he was always distracted by the
girls the other guy was arrogance the
other guy was ethics the other guy was a
Christian guy who was very happy he
reached a number and he was cool with it
he didn't want to keep continuing going
he was doing good for himself no problem
but eventually you learned who the real
big thinker was time
reveals a lot of things time reveals a
good friendship time reveals a good
relationship time reveals a good economy
time reveals a bad policy time reveals a
good politician time reveals a good
Administration Time Will Reveal
everything it's either your best friend
or your worst enemy nobody beats time
nobody time is going to get you if you
do right eventually the Market's going
to say listen man whether you like this
guy or not we got to give him credit
when you were screaming off the top of
your lungs how amazing your policies
were about the funding to police like
Tom said guess what it's show now
ah not a good idea not a good idea we're
leaving you when you were screaming
about the fact that hey let's put double
mask and all this stuff in the state of
California and do you remember when it
was text people who are not wearing a
mask or they're out there not respecting
the uh what is it the uh non-essential
text and we'll give you 200 if you can
tell people who are out there snitching
on them that's mayor Garcetti when they
had the texting concept yeah guess what
yeah people don't want that they left
yeah bad policies eventually get exposed
you cannot fake bad policies so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]